- [male] Yo. Do you want
to go get a mermaid frap?
- Okay.
- [Male] Let's go.
- Alright.
- Okay.
- [Male] Let's go.
(girls laugh)
(whimsical whistling music)
(laughs)
- You're so judgy.
(whimsical whistling music)
- [Male] Alright so this
is our Mermaid frap.
Apparently it's real hard to make.
The drizzle is all gone already.
I appreciate it. So.
- You know, this was a
mermaid on a hot day.
- [Male] Let's taste it.
- Okay.
- [Male] Okay.
- It's good, I like it. I mean.
- I don't hate this.
- [Male] I taste vanilla.
- And green tea a little bit.
- I taste a hint of green tea.
- Yeah.
- [Male] There's like a little
- And like a little bit of berry.
It almost tastes like,
melted vanilla ice cream.
And a berry smoothie had a baby
and the baby had like
a fling with some matcha.
(laughs)
- [Male] That's quite a
description you did there.
- It's like a mixture of
vanilla and berries and
there's a texture.
The seeds right?
They're the seeds right?
- [Woman In white] Yeah. Mmhm.
- Is this the seeds? Yeah.
- We tried the unicorn together.
- Yeah.
- [Male] Is this better than unicorn frap?
- Yeah, this is better
than unicorn frap for me.
- Yeah I like the berries.
It tricks you into thinking
that it might be healthy
because the texture
reminds me of a smoothie.
- [Male] Signing off.
- Signing off. Peace!
(funk music)